you mentioned elijah before yes um
i i i
and i i remembered a connection that not
many i think uh actors share but i i'm
told that you
you both and elijah and maybe sean all
have matching tattoos is that right
mm-hmm
are they visible yes yeah well it's
massive
yeah it's myself elijah shawn
billy orlando vigo ian mckellen john
reese davis is stunt double oh sean bean
yeah sean beam all nine of the
fellowship well nine of the festival a
very cool thing happened when we went
back to new zealand a couple years later
pete jackson very proudly showed us a
tattoo that he got which instead of the
number nine which we got he got the
number ten oh as a kind of like you know
just outside the group piggyback
on the party
so that me that means the number nine in
elvish high elvish i think right
which is the language that only the
kings and queens and royal court in the
elvis community the reason i bring this
up is me and my my fellows my my group
of critical role yeah to emulate you
we all got matching tattoos
i was just about to say you guys should
do we did we have vox machina tattoos
each of us i i'd have to like take off
my shirt i'll show you but it's it's on
it's on my shoulder have you all got it
on the same place no no some of us got
it on their arms i think someone has it
on their calf i have it on my back
but yeah we did the same
[Music]
me and hold thing tight all through the
night you're shining bright i'm your
host the baby you're my pearl